a very rare diamond
[Music]
that's the sound of time pass in time
person there's still loads of time
passing
it's been 84 years it's okay
okay so new mutants is now finally out
in cinemas
and i feel like there's a lot we need to
talk about i'm not only going to be
going over the movie's full plot
but also the production troubles that
it's faced over the years
because god damn now throughout this
video
we're just gonna be going over
everything you need to know about the
film and because of this
there will be heavy spoilers if you
enjoy it then please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
without the way this is the heavy
spoiler show i'm your host definition
aka the new mutant that turned into an
old one waiting for this film
now let's get into the breakdown
okay so new mutants feels like a film
that was never gonna come out
i can't remember something that's been
delayed this much and it seems like such
a long time ago
since we saw the first trailer all the
way back in 2017
this teaser provided a unique take on
the comic book movie
and it initially appeared to be a horror
before the studio decided that it was
too much of a risk to take
thus further reshoots were planned which
would change several aspects of the film
and the movie suffered its first delay
however there were rumors that the
reshoots were actually going to be a lot
more substantial
and that they would pretty much require
refilming over half of the movie
fox wanted to avoid the flop that was
fanfare stick
whilst also being different enough that
it felt like something that would stand
out
similar to logan and deadpool during
this time the disney fox merger was also
taking place
a lot of things were up in the air and
it seemed like there would be major
changes in the studio structure
that would severely alter its lineup
however there was a clause in the
contract that stated new mutants would
have to be released theoretically
and this is why the film has been
dropped in cinemas instead of on
streaming services
disney begrudgingly took this on but
decided that investing in reshoots
wasn't going to be worth the return on
investment thus
they placed it back into their release
schedule minus the reshoots
and the film is pretty much how it was
originally intended to be
however the pandemic caused a major
shift in the movie business
and thus they took it off their lineup
on may the 4th it was reported that the
film had been listed for media pre-order
on amazon
and some lawyers must have got involved
as the listing was taken down
almost immediately it went back and
forth for weeks over whether the film
would see the light of day
before disney eventually just decided to
dump it at the end of august
with little marketing and probably in
the mindset that
they just want the entire thing over
with so yay
who's excited now i actually went into
this film
quite optimistic even with the low
rotten tomatoes scored 22 percent
which was based off nine reviews and
let's be honest man that's not enough
opinions to gain a critical consensus
but yeah since then
even with the added reviews the score
hasn't really moved up that much but you
know
i was still like well it might be good
and you know what
it's okay now as for the plot itself we
open with the same clip that was shown
at comic-con at home the narration is
given to us by danny moonstar
and she tells us that when she was
growing up her father told her
that within everyone exists two bears
one evil and one good
which bear wins depends on which bear
you feed the most
and dany has been told throughout her
life that it is possible to conquer the
darkness within her
her father gave her a small bear
necklace which was meant to represent
how small the evil bear once was
however as it feeds on fear there is a
worry that this metaphorical bear
has grown as dany has too now in the
opening it seems like her home is
devastated by a tornado
but it is revealed that this is a
manifestation of the bear
which is brought on by dany's powers
throughout the film we learn that dany
is capable
of taking one's darkest desires or
greatest fears
and bringing them to life she's pretty
much the jason striker of the film
and throughout she learns how to control
her powers dany's father is murdered in
front of her
by the bear who then chases her through
the woods before she falls faster than
disney stalks
and gets knocked out it's here that she
wakes up in a hospital
run by a doctor named cecilia reyes who
tells her that they're in an institution
that's been built to house mutants
reyes informs dany that she's a mutant
herself and were introduced to the other
members of the cast
now clearly from the off this is a sort
of twist on xavier's school for gifted
youngsters
whereas his mansion was overseen by a
mutant who is able to read people's
minds
and therefore be empathetic towards them
reyes's power
involves generating force fields this
idea of shutting things out
definitely ties into her as a character
and she very much keeps the truth
guarded from the group she too is part
of balls herself
and doesn't really see the teens as
people more they're simply animals to
her
they're initially under the impression
that they're being trained to be part of
the x-men
but this is soon revealed to be a lie
and it's actually the essex corporation
behind it
if you're up to speed with the x-men
franchise you'll remember that they
collected wolverine's dna at the weapon
x facility
now it does hint that this film is
actually connected to logan
and that if the group passed this
screening phase they'll be shipped off
to a facility to be trained as weapons
there's also lip service given to the
mutant population dying out
and though we don't get a specific time
period for the film
i would say that it falls in just before
logan
however it's pretty much a standalone
movie and disney don't do any efforts to
connect it to the grand
mcu now as for the lineup i actually
think that they work really well and
each one of them is pretty memorable
normally in team-up films you get some
that become lost by the wayside
but i did feel that each one of these
leaves an impression
the first one i want to talk about is
anya taylor joy who's playing ileana
rasputin
why why here first because god damn now
rasputin is actually the sister of
colossus in the comics
however as mentioned earlier they don't
really make any connections
and beyond being able to armor up she
might as well be a different entity
on top of this eliana is capable of
traveling into a dimension
known as limbo where her powers derive
from
it seems like she has a stuffed animal
also known as lockheed
but this does take form by the end now
we do learn that she was forced into
child slavery when she was younger
and has been chased by mysterious
monsters known as the smiley men for
most of her life
they sort of become big villains as dany
manifests them into reality
and though it's clearly ripping off the
gentleman from buffy the vampire slayer
they do show the episode at one point in
the movie so hey
at least they're admitting it i suppose
now next up is maisie william
who plays rain sinclair sinclair's
monika is wolf spain
and as you can guess she has the ability
to transform into a dog
she's probably one of the most
interesting characters in the film and
sinclair group in a very religious
village and fled it due to the hate that
she faced
josh boone the film's director stated
that he grew up with very strict
religious parents
which formed the basis of her character
and you can probably tell as she gets
the most development
charlie heaton plays sam guthrie who's
able to fly at supersonic speeds
henry zagar plays roberto de costa who
can control solar energy
and lastly of course is dany she and
rayne become the film's emotional heart
and their relationship becomes a big
focal point
now what unites these characters is that
all of them have been struck with great
tragedy
and in most cases their powers
manifesting
led to the death of someone close to
them they're haunted by visions of their
past
and this is eventually revealed to be
dany's powers coming to fruition
unsure of what to do with this reyes
reaches out to her employers
who are revealed to be the essex
corporation and they order her to kill
dany
reign suspects something's not right and
catches reyes in the act
cutting her face up before she flees the
team also fight the smiley men
and after defeating them they track down
reyes in order to get free
reyes argues that dany is too dangerous
to live because she's unable to control
her power
and this would very much lead to a jason
striker situation
if she were allowed to roam free the
group stand beside her
but due to the treatment that reyes put
it through her subconscious is run wild
and the demon bear manifests once more
eating
reyes yikes now it's here that the group
really come together in order to fight
the beast
however dany is the only one who can
stop it in her subconscious she comes
face to face with her father
who tells her that it's time to face a
fear the character awakens from her
phase of sleep
is that is that a scientific term but i
don't know terrible script writing
anyway
she steps forward calms down the bear
and thus
controls it this is of course a metaphor
for dany controlling her own fear
and therefore gaining control of her
power the group stand outside the
hospital
and realize that the force field is down
and head out into the world
which ends the film i probably shouldn't
call this an end and explained
which i might not do in the end now as
for what could happen going forward
well i i don't actually think that we
will be seeing the characters again
josh boone did state that he had
something for a post-credits scene
however he didn't put it in the eventual
release because
he didn't think there would be any
sequels going forward and
it was just completely unlikely that
anything else would happen
i think that this group would have
actually fit in pretty well with the
ones that we saw at the end of logan
but it does look like disney is indeed
scrapping the idea of the new mutants
going forward due to their removal of
the scene which
would have put things in place for next
time now as for my thoughts on the film
i'm actually surprised it got delayed as
much as it did
i really don't think that this is the
train wreck that everyone thought it
would be
i know the reshoots might have added
something it's not completely abysmal
dark phoenix is still the worst x-men
movie to me and then probably
wolverine origins after it sure this
isn't anything amazing that you must
rush out and see
and potentially risk your life for but
meh it's not
it's not bad overall i don't think i'll
be watching it again
but it's fine yeah it's it's fine you
know what
i'm gonna give it a six out of ten now
that's new mutants
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it so make sure you comment below and
let me know
if you enjoy this video then please drop
a thumbs up and if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of tennis which is
gonna be linked at the end
that film actually needs a breakdown now
we're also giving away a free copy of
the avengers on any console of your
choice
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below the win is going to be
chosen at random on the 30th of august
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the join button below
you can also come chat us on a discord
server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you mean the best i've been definition
i'll see you next time take care
[Music]
peace
i